粉丝说你眼睛
怎么这么好
这字那么小
你都看得很清楚
我之所以能够
不费力的看小字
是因为我有个
保养眼睛的秘诀
而且这个秘诀做了以后
还能够帮助你
改善老花近视
以及眼睛的酸痛
你学起来的话
绝对是一生受用
胡乃文开讲啰
我是你的老朋友胡医师
70岁看小字好清楚
5穴救老花近视
来喔马上跟你说
我到了70岁
不用戴老花眼镜的秘密
就是这一招
把手这样卷起来
哎美丽的太太
你跟我一起做好吗
好啊
把手这样卷起来
然后放在你的眼眶上面
有几个穴道
攒竹
鱼腰
瞳子髎
承泣
睛明
就这几个穴呢
常常这样子
揉一揉揉一揉
就这样揉
就这样揉一揉
要揉多久
大概一两分钟
两三分钟都可以
我们再按一次
这里眉头
攒竹
鱼腰
然后再来边边
瞳子髎
还有眼睛下方
这个叫做
承泣
另外在鼻子的两边
眼睛的内侧
这个叫做睛明
就这样子
做一次再做两次做三次
因为有点痛
所以也不要做太长时间
只是点到为止的
这样做一做
我跟你讲
将来你的眼睛
就跟我差不多了
黄帝内经里头说
五脏六腑之精气
皆上注于目
意思就是你的精气
你的气血
都会供应到眼睛去
所以你的眼睛好不好
也应对着你的身体的状况
你如果长时间
盯着萤幕或者是看股票
看的眼睛都酸痛
赶快按摩
这个地方一两圈
就这样子按一按
已经有老花的人
也能够透过按摩
来改善你的眼睛
这个地方的循环
而且能够
延缓你的眼睛的老化退化
很讚喔
回家可以教
阿公阿嬷
爸爸妈妈
全家一起按起来
最棒天然眼药
每天一小把
5天抗眼干
美丽的太太你知道吗
台湾干眼症的人
有六百万人
意思就是说办公室里头
10个人
就有2-3个人
眼睛干干的涩涩的
天天要滴点眼药水
才可以喔
我跟你说
有一个很棒的
天然眼药
1周就能让你缓解
眼睛干涩
它就是枸杞这个东西
研究证实中年健康的人
每周吃5天
1次1小把
连续吃那个90天
黄斑色素密度
立刻的
上升明显
并且保护视网膜的效果
比吃补充品
还要更棒喔
动物上面的实验
都证明了
吃了枸杞的萃取物
它的眼泪的量也会增加
角膜损伤也减少了
甚至于改善了干眼症
怎么吃枸杞最有效呢
我教你两招
第一招上班族当零食吃
是最方便喔
抓几个枸杞咚咚吃下去
当零食来吃
嘴巴里面
还不会觉得不舒服
眼睛干疲劳都能够舒缓
一定有人会问
枸杞一天能吃几颗呀
吃一小把
大概十几二十颗吧
第二招枸杞菊花决明子一起泡
枸杞决明子菊花
一起泡着来喝
帮助眼睛血液的循环
一周就能感受到
眼睛变得水亮的
非常舒服
买决明子的时候
有个秘诀
我建议你到
中药房买的时候呢
买生的买炒的各一半
生的跟炒的
为什么呢
因为生的可以帮助
泻一点点火
帮助排便也很好
因为这样不容易上火
也能改善血脂肪
帮助眼睛的血液循环
接下来我们请小芬示范怎么泡
枸杞菊花决明子茶
我们来泡一个
准备材料有三种
枸杞5克
菊花3克
决明子5克
你将全部的材料呢
放入杯子或是茶壶中
再倒入300~500cc的热水
焖泡15分钟
就能喝囉
那枸杞怎么
分辨好和坏呢
最重要的
你不要只是看这一个
你看它的这个蒂头
这蒂头有没有跟这个
枸杞的颜色完全一样的
这种你不要买
那个就是染色的
枸杞有它的橙色对不对
那上面那个蒂头呢
应该是比它的颜色要淡
有点白色的
那这就不是染色
而是天然就是那样子的
还有那个太红太漂亮
可能闻起来还有点酸味的
那就不要买
要选颗粒大没有农药
没有防腐剂
没有色素
还是有机认证的
吃得安心又有效
不是手机
2习惯
让孩子近视飙高
有些妈妈说
她都不让小孩滑手机了
怎么还是近视
其实近视的主要原因
不是萤幕
而是长时间近距离来用眼睛
像是距离不到3公尺看电视
或者距离不到30公分
写字读书
这些才是
真正让眼睛
吃不消的原因
孩子容易近视
常常都是
两个习惯养成的
握笔的方式
读书的姿势
我们先讲小朋友握笔
来写字怎么写
我们现在看到小孩
太小的时候
就开始学习写字
大概读幼稚园
或者是才三岁五岁
妈妈就说
你拿个笔画个图
写个字啊
你知道小孩子的手没有力
拿起笔来啊
这样才有力啊
这样写
这样写的时候
你看眼睛看不见
所以呢
你必须眼睛这样子
歪下去
看那 假如说
你能够改变这个习惯
就像我这样子写字就好了
可是小孩子没力啊
他拿起来就是那样子
那么这样子的话
眼睛就太近距离
看所画的东西
所写的东西
还有呢
读书的时候
有的时候头会累啊
就这样子读书
这样子读书的话
眼睛就偏了
对不对
离那个纸太近了
我小的时候啊
我爸爸教我写字啊
那个光线
从左 前方这样下来
然后呢他叫我
把这个头就一定是这样子
这样写
眼睛要离那个字距呢
大约25-30公分
这样才好
所以我一直到现在
都还受益于这个
所以假如说
你家有小孩子
还很小呢
你也学习我这样子
将来他到了80岁
仍然眼睛非常的好
1动作放松睫状肌
防近视度数
往上狂飙
美丽的太太
你知道现在的孩子
近视真的是越来越早了
对不对
是啊
幼儿园大班的近视小孩呢
就快有一成
10个人里头就有1个
小学一年级的时候
就飙到两成
六年级的时候更夸张
直接到七成之多
这么小就近视
还要戴眼镜
这样不是很难过
来来来
我教你一个简单的方法
准备一支笔
就像我手上这样
有一支笔
你拿着这个笔呢
练习看远看近
怎么做你知道吗
把这个笔放在这里
看得清楚吗
很清楚
然后呢慢慢慢慢拉远
也一定看得很清楚
看得很清楚
然后从远拉近的时候
看得很清楚吧
就是这个焦距
就一直放在这个笔上
然后拉近拉近拉近
拉到最近
就再拉远一点
然后渐渐的拉远
渐渐的拉远
你常常这样练习
就可以一直看得
有一个距离看东西
这样眼睛
就不容易得近视了
做这个刚讲的笔尖
近远近远的训练呢
就像帮眼睛
做一个伸展操
它一下子拉直一下放松
一下拉直一下放松
这样子的话呢
就使眼睛做了
伸展运动了
把僵硬的肌肉放松开来
让睫状肌非常的灵活
度数就不会快速加深
甚至于已经近视的人
你常常做这种训练
也很好
我们小编他近视500度
他还透过这样子的训练时间呢
大概将近一年了
看远方比以前他说清楚好多
那我们去打
羽毛球棒球
眼睛一直来回
看那 是不是也可以啊
当然
研究显示啊
每周多一小时的户外运动
近视的风险就降低2%
相反的
每周多滑一小时的手机
近视风险你知道多少
就增加6个百分点
所以呢
带着孙子
去户外动一动
才是预防近视眼的最好方法
不只是眼睛变好
感情也变得更亲密哦
那不是一兼二顾
一兼二顾
摸蜊仔兼洗裤
哈哈哈
我台语讲得准不准
爱喝即溶咖啡伤眼
3食物也少吃
我跟你说啊
有一个东西会伤眼
就是即溶咖啡
我们以前吃了很多的即溶咖啡
好
研究显示呢
他说习惯于喝即溶咖啡的人
眼睛黄斑病变的风险
竟然比一般人高多少
你知道吗
7倍
啊
即溶咖啡会伤眼睛哦
即溶咖啡在制造的过程当中
会产生两种有害物质
丙烯醯胺和糖化的终产物
它们会让视网膜产生氧化压力
慢性发炎
久了就容易造成眼睛细胞的退化
而在台湾呢
黄斑部并变其实是很常见的
65岁以上的人
大概每十个里头就有一个
所以爱喝即溶咖啡的人
建议你不要
天天喝
除了即溶咖啡
这3种食物也会伤眼
第1种高糖食物
加速眼睛老化
血管的损伤
第2种高脂肪食物
让血液的黏稠度增加
眼睛的血液循环就变不好了
第3种冰冷的食物
冰品生鱼片等等
中医认为吃冰品就不好
那我们用现在的观念
来讲的话呢
会收缩血管气血不畅
气血不畅
让眼睛不要太寒凉
很重要
像我自己也用蒸气眼罩
来放松我的眼睛呢
第二步才是进补的方法
护眼睛你可以吃
含叶黄素虾红素的食物
有叶黄素的食物有什么呢
像深绿色的蔬菜
例如菠菜绿花椰菜
帮助你吸收蓝光
保护你的黄斑部
虾红素的食物
例如鲑鱼虾子等等
这些海鲜
消除眼睛的疲劳抗氧化
不是只有不滑手机
不是只有不看近物
而是连食物你都得要注意哦